Hello
Wake Up!
I don't know when you're gonna call. So when would I sleep when I'm not calling?
No, it's not unreasonable at all
Excuse me!
I take it the boss lady's on a warpath this morning
Every Morning
Move!!
Ding Dong! Ding Dong!
Really think I could help this company
You just gave me a chance just concentrate on being my assistant where you always mean
I got big and I got rich so now we're gonna check me boo. I wish you were my age and I check you I
I wish you were little
I told you watch it
Screams
What the Hell black Jesus?
How did you go from this to this? To this?
You went to bed grown and then you woke up little
that's for white people cuz black people don't have the time
Child Protective Services enroll this child in school or somebody is going to jail. Somebody do you mean
Shorten everyone else. You're a child. So you have to start acting like it get back to work
whose child is this?
Walking around here in this tiny pink pant suit?
Super babies all across the world
I need you to cover for me in the office. I should really dress the part.
your body can't fit into my clothes. This is squad
Lottie's that body looks like babyGap Gymboree #gospel. Gosh to me body
Damn girl lookin like cookie from Empire
There's your teacher
Damn...
Could tell that you are a special young lady
I feel I could get really I feel like I get you - so you feel what I'm feeling?
No, I'm not feeling that at all. Don't don't look at me like that
You just look look look at the other way. Look through it. Look the look up there
What is going on
Is this rich people's house mates?
You can do better than that!
Whoo!
Well, I'm April. "A" for available
Think you're the boss of me think one more thing. I dare you. You're too fat for that skirt, okay
See I've been looking at you like a little girl, but you a grown-ass woman. We have a BMW situation black mama whooping
I told you not to tempt me Yes!
Start Spanking your kids!
I obey my mama...